all right it took a little bit of time
but this is what I came up with this is
the same code that we had before and
really the only new parts here are
iterating through the dates and the
descriptions for each job here I'm doing
the same thing we did before I'm
replacing some data from the HTML work
date string with the dates from my work
object and then I'm appending the
formatted dates to the last element of
class work entry same thing with
description I'm replacing the
placeholder data with work jobs job
description and then appending the
formatted version to the last element of
class work entry and this is what we see
on the page